when you know enough about your data
you can help your machine connect the
dots with supervised learning
in supervised learning you show the
machine the connection between different
variables and known outcomes
in machine learning this is called the
supervised learning
it's called supervised learning because
it's already tagged with identifying
information
imagine you wanted to train a machine to
help you predict how long it will take
you to drive home
you would start by creating a set of
labeled data
this data would include weather
conditions time of day and whether it's
a holiday
these are your inputs the output would
be the amount of time it took to drive
home on that particular day
in this case your independent variables
would be the input and your dependent
variable would be the output
here you want to use different machine
learning algorithms to map the
relationships between these different
variables
you can use statistical regression for
this and determine how the independent
variables affect the dependent variable
you intuitively know that if it's
raining outside it will take you longer
to drive home
but machines have to rely on data and
statistics
they have to look at the length of your
commute and compare it to labeled data
it has on the weather
let's see how we can create a supervised
machine learning model to help us
determine our commute time
the first thing you want to do is create
a training set
based on this training set your machine
might see there's a direct
relationship between the amount of rain
and the time it takes to get home
the more it rains the longer you'll be
on the road
it might also see there's a connection
between the time you leave work and the
time you'll be on the road
the closer you are to 5 pm the longer it
takes for you to get home
your machine finds some of the
relationships with your labeled data
this is the start of your data model it
begins to understand concepts like how
rain impacts the way people drive
it also starts to see that there are
more people who travel during certain
times of day
then your machine takes this training
set and applies it to a test
set of your data it looks to see if the
model in this training set holds true
when you're looking at many more days
you could ask the computer to predict
how long it will take you to drive home
each day
and then give it feedback on how
accurate it was in its prediction
over time the machine will learn and
adapt its model to improve the output
your machine will continue to tune the
model in the training set
and you can make adjustments based on
the new data
this is pretty similar to how humans
learn
think about when you learned how to
drive you started in a small parking lot
with an adult guiding you
then you got to the point where you
could drive predictably and safely in
this smaller space
then once you built up enough confidence
you'd head out into the open road
you won't learn everything you need to
know about driving in the parking lot
but you should get enough data to help
you get started
chances are you'll still learn a lot of
new skills and hopefully you'll continue
to improve over time until you become an
expert driver
the key thing to remember is that in
supervised machine learning you know a
lot more about the training data
you can feed labeled data into the
machine that's easily classified
so with your commute home you know more
about the weather holidays and time of
day
this labeled data is the key difference
between supervised
learning and other forms of machine
learning